[Música]
cuántos de ustedes se han enamorado
alguna vez probablemente les ha pasado
varias veces en la vida y si yo les
pregunto qué es lo primero que les viene
a la mente cuando piensan en una pareja
lo más seguro es que piensen en una
pareja de un chico con una chica porque
así nos lo han mostrado la mayoría de
películas series y novelas
el tema es que estas historias de amor
que siempre nos han mostrado como entre
comillas normales no son las únicas que
existen también hay otras que salen
menos en las películas y en la tele como
las que vivimos dos mujeres dos hombres
o dos personas de género no binario y
que también son historias de amor pero
yo todavía recuerdo como si fuera ayer
cuando me decían una y otra vez que si
eres mujer te tienen que gustar los
hombres y que si eres hombre te tienen
que gustar las mujeres entonces para mí
eso fue un conflicto muy grande porque
desde los 8 años yo ya sentía que me
gustaban las mujeres pero eso era todo
lo opuesto a lo que todo el mundo
que me tenía que usar a pesar de lo
retador que fue ya cuando tenía 15 años
pude empezar a comprender que el amor
que yo puedo sentir hacia otra mujer es
igual de natural que el amor que siente
una pareja heterosexual los amores entre
dos mujeres dos hombres o dos personas
de género no binario son historias de
amor como cualquier otra dos personas
que se gustan
luego se enamoran luego se comprometen y
deciden pasar el resto de su vida juntas
o sea historias de amor de parejas
enamoradas y como cualquier pareja
enamorada
queremos demostrarnos lo que sentimos
abrazarnos besarnos hacer lo mismo que
hacen las otras parejas
pero esto puede ser peligroso cuando se
trata de una pareja que no está
conformada por un hombre con una mujer
porque el solo hecho de salir a caminar
agarrados de la mano o darnos una
muestra de afecto en público puede hacer
que algunas personas nos juzguen o nos
digan que no estamos dando un buen
ejemplo a los niños que llamen a
serenazgo oa la policía e incluso otras
personas pueden llegar a agredirnos con
insultos o con golpes dejando huellas
mucho más profundas y esta situación se
agrava cuando quienes nos juzgan y nos
critican son los mismos que toman las
decisiones en los distintos niveles de
gobierno porque ellos también piensan
que nos deberíamos quedar dentro de
nuestras cuatro paredes incluso una
ministra de estado cuando le preguntaron
en una entrevista sobre las parejas del
mismo sexo ella dijo que no se metía en
temas de alcoba y lo dijo en el año 2020
como si estuviésemos haciendo algo malo
nos tratan como si fuéramos ciudad
años de segunda categoría
y además de estas personas y autoridades
saben quiénes más nos tratan de esta
forma tan injusta el conjunto de leyes
que nos castiga por no formar una pareja
entre comillas normal por salirnos de lo
que se espera o por no estar dentro de
la norma nuestro país que simplemente no
nos reconoce dentro de la ley a cuántas
parejas ustedes conocen que se hayan
casado aqui en el peru les doy la
respuesta ninguna ninguna porque en el
perú el principal requisito para casarse
es que uno sea hombre y la otra sea
mujer no importa cuánto nos queremos ni
importa cuánto tiempo hemos estado
juntas si se trata de una pareja formada
por dos hombres o dos mujeres
el matrimonio simplemente no está
disponible para nosotros
para mí esta es una de las formas más
crueles de castigarnos de obligar a las
parejas del mismo sexo a que vivamos
nuestra convivencia por gran parte de
nuestras vidas en el más absoluto
desamparo legal y que significa este
desamparo legal significa que en el perú
cuando una pareja conformada por un
hombre con una mujer decide casarse la
sociedad no solamente celebra su amor
sino que además les otorga una serie de
derechos que protege su vida en pareja
por ejemplo pueden ser dueños de su
patrimonio compartido de sus bienes su
casa su dinero sus pertenencias y que
ninguna persona externa pueda venir a
quitárselos pueden tomar decisiones
médicas en caso de emergencia sobre su
pareja algo que empieza con una cosa tan
sencilla como poder acompañarle dentro
de la habitación si la otra persona está
hospitalizada pueden inscribirse como
beneficiario de su seguro médico de
salud público o privado
para que la otra persona pueda tener
cobertura médica pueden recibir la
pensión de jubilación o de cualquier
otro seguro en caso que la otra persona
fallezca y así otros la mayoría de
parejas heterosexuales ni siquiera se
cuestiona la existencia de estos
derechos porque son tan naturales que
los dan por sentado en cambio para
nosotros dar por sentados estos derechos
es imposible porque literalmente no
tenemos ni uno les voy a poner un
ejemplo en junio falleció luis repetto
él fue el ex director del instituto
nacional de cultura fue un promotor de
los museos y de la marinera fue un
defensor de nuestro patrimonio histórico
y cultural fue una persona entregada al
perú y también era gay y al mes de su
fallecimiento al mes cuando su pareja
jonathan huamaní ni siquiera se estaba
recuperando del dolor que puede sentir
una persona cuando pierde a su compañero
de vida la familia de luís lo estaba
desalojando de su departamento porque no
quisieron
aceptar que esa era su casa la que
compartía con louis porque se negaron a
reconocer que ellos estaban juntos por
ocho años a jonathan lo dejaron salir
únicamente con una mochila y eso lo
sabemos porque lo vimos en las noticias
porque louis era una persona muy
conocida pero ninguna ley reconoce a
jonathan como el viudo de louis
qué protección podría haber tenido
jonathan sin la que otorga el matrimonio
civil qué pasa con todas las otras
injusticias que no salen en los
noticieros pero que afectan
terriblemente a nuestras parejas estamos
viviendo una de las peores crisis
sanitarias en la historia del perú
cuantos de las 70.000 personas que han
fallecido en lo que va de la pandemia
tenían una pareja del mismo sexo con la
que no se pudieron casar
cuántos tenían una pareja que se ha
quedado a la suerte de los familiares
cuantos no pueden cobrar la pensión de
su pareja porque ante la ley no son el
beneficiario cuantos de los miles que
han perdido su trabajo durante la
pandemia no pueden beneficiarse del
seguro médico de su pareja
todo esto pasa porque el perú es un país
que no reconoce el matrimonio
igualitario y solamente en américa
latina' el matrimonio es legal para
cualquier pareja en argentina brasil
colombia ecuador y uruguay
pronto lo va a hacer en chile y en
bolivia se acaba de inscribir el primer
matrimonio entre dos hombres en cambio
el perú sigue siendo una isla de atraso
en medio de tanto progreso donde las
parejas del mismo sexo no se nos valora
y donde no existimos en ninguna ley y
donde no tenemos ninguno de los derechos
ni de las protecciones que nos otorgaría
el matrimonio civil somos uno de los
países más injustos del continente y no
por falta de oportunidades hace sólo un
mes el tribunal constitucional de
nuestro país decidió darle la espalda a
la oportunidad histórica que tuvieron de
hacer justicia y prefirió no permitirle
a oscar ugarteche y fidel la noche que
se casaron en mexico en el 2010
inscribir su matrimonio en el perú y
esto es un derecho que tiene oscar como
peruano y la máxima corte en nuestro
país prefirió no hacer nada al respecto
la máxima corte de nuestro país prefirió
que un hombre casado siga siendo tratado
como soltero en su país natal únicamente
porque se casó con una persona de su
mismo sexo no es justo que nuestro país
nos ponga tantos obstáculos no solamente
para ser felices sino para ser iguales y
tampoco es justo que la única solución
para muchas personas sea tener que
mudarse a otro país donde si se van a
respetar sus derechos
no podemos seguir haciendo como si estas
injusticias no sucedieran delante de
nuestros ojos porque mientras la mayoría
de peruanos sigue siendo indiferente
millones de personas tenemos que seguir
luchando contra la corriente para que
nuestro país las leyes nos traten como
iguales cualquier persona que haya
entendido esto
y crea que las parejas que estamos
viviendo en el perú vivimos una
situación injusta tiene que levantarse y
decir que esto no puede seguir
sucediendo todos juntos podemos unirnos
para cambiar a nuestro país y hacer que
sea uno más justo para todas las
personas que vivimos en el el próximo
año nuestro país cumple 200 años y si
alzamos nuestras voces y nos unimos en
este reclamo el perú del bicentenario
puede ser un país en el que todas las
parejas tienen los mismos derechos y
todas las familias tienen la misma
protección donde cualquier pareja pueda
unirse en matrimonio civil por eso yo
les pregunto cómo es el país que
queremos dejarle a las generaciones del
futuro cómo es el país en el que ustedes
quieren que crezcan sus hijos
el perú del bicentenario el país donde
todas las personas seamos iguales en las
leyes y en las calles necesita del
empuje de todos nosotros nos merecemos
ese país que nos separa sino que incluye
que no discrimina por nuestra
orientación sexual y donde podemos
pensar en el futuro al lado de la
persona que amamos con optimismo y no
con temor
entonces así como cuando las personas
que se van a casar dicen si acepto
seamos un país que dice si acepto a la
igualdad para que todas las parejas se
puedan casar si acepto a un país que no
discrimina y que respeta a todas las
familias si acepto a un perú justo unido
y acogedor hagamos de nuestra lucha por
justicia la de todo el país y digamos si
acepto al matrimonio igualitario
gracias
[Música]